how did you make the decision the choice
to say I don't want this life instead of
spend your energy in that space up or
complaining all the time we switch it
into that well solution so what I what
can I do was first serve yourself before
you can serve with the people the sooner
you start the faster you're gonna fail
the more you get done this is the bridge
that most people can't cross ladies and
gentlemen if you don't know mr. John Lee
he is a successful entrepreneur out of
the UK super quick story he came his
parents were immigrants from from China
to the UK they started a family
restaurant that John had to work for
washing dishes wasn't very good at
school getting D grades but decided that
he wanted to turn his life around and
not end up in that business he started
getting to real estate had his first
deal I think was 85,000 for his first
deal sold that property two months later
for a hundred and eighty five I became a
millionaire by age twenty-seven now owns
over 200 different real estate
properties he's part of the wealth
dragons movement I call it a movement
because I think it started off as a book
that focus on real estate and
entrepreneurship but it's now expanded
into an app where there's tons of
courses you can learn from different
mentors on everything around
entrepreneurship including certain
YouTube channel and having a course on
that which I'm excited for John welcome
aboard man so great you connect with you
finally so what I'm super curious about
is how did you make the decision the
choice to say however long ago 20 odd
years ago I don't want this life I'm
gonna be a successful real estate
investor like what I don't know how old
you were when you first started learning
about it but but the mind said that so
many people have of Here I am washing
dishes doing a boring job that I don't
like how did you make that switch to say
I could be something better I think it
happened when you know sometimes you
work in a job you always think to
yourself there's got to be a better way
of doing things and you see all these
other people do it but then you don't
really know how to do it and so it
wasn't until
made that Constitution that you know I
was working the job and some someone
pointing the finger and said you're
fired
sounds too good at my job I was a
computer animator right so I was working
in the animation and I was you know
working on some great films I work for a
company called EA games and then I went
through a lot of the corporate bullying
and then when I got five my job I said
to myself I'm never gonna let anyone
point the finger and say you're fired
and so that's when I took my I guess
future into my own hands
and aim was real estate the first thing
real estate was the first thing yeah I
mean see I mean you know I wasn't that
smart so I just thought if I can just
buy a house at a very cheap price and I
sell at a higher price then it's gonna
be easy for me to replace my income so
that's exactly what I did how did you go
so this is where a lot of people get
stuck because they they get fired or or
they're in a job that they hate but
their solution isn't a proactive one
which was yours like I'm gonna make a
better life myself I'm gonna learn about
real estate their solution is well this
job sucks my life sucks that boss sucked
how did you have that intuition the
leaning on proactivity
instead of complaining so I remember my
friend told me story once I said like
because I was one of those complainers
if I just never lesson on this we call
them BMWs [ __ ] Moniz or whiners I
want people so what are the things that
I said to myself I said you know what
I'm not going to like you can complain
about a problem but actually what you
need to focus on is instead of spend
your energy in that space of complaining
all the time we switch it into that well
solution so what I what can I do so
instead of complaining about it like
what I what can I do my friend said
Tommy story
it's called John and his dog so doc
John's Sammy's is pote dog comes out
starts going oh oh do all these moaning
noises mr. Smith come down and says
don't - the dog keep doing that and then
John says oh it's okay and mrs. Smith
their job or the dog always moans
because sat on a rusty nail it hurts
enough for the doctor moan but it
doesn't hurt enough for the dog to get
off the nail and I heard that story I'm
like oh my god I'm the dog I notice
complaining about my like my job my life
not getting paid enough and then so
I decided to you know what I'm just
gonna do it I'm gonna try it what what
what do I have to lose what was your
reaction the people around you your
parents your friends your family
completely like you're insane
do you know the day I quit my job I got
I got my salad was 36,000 pounds and the
Deaf quit my job I went I doubled my my
literally someone gave me double for a
60 thousand and I turned it down because
I know that if I take that job I've got
more responsibility I don't have freedom
and what I want to do is is to be able
to make an income and also have my
freedom to do what I love to do so your
parents your friends your family think
you're crazy
yep you just lost your job you got an
opportunity to double your salary you
said no are you are you moving back home
do you have enough savings to stay where
you are like how did you Hank that this
is the bridge that most people can't
cross so how did you cross that bridge
so what I was doing when I was working
my job I was doing a side hustle so I
was going to lots of networking events
so I met an investor and I said to the
investor I said look why don't you fund
me through this so I did a pitch and I
had to go through a number of pictures
and this guy ended up giving me 20,000
pounds so when I quit my job I now had
some funds to start and I stole my car I
sold my Honda s2000 convertible for a
beat up in a Ford Mondeo and I was
driving around that in a couple years
and and yeah I was kind of living on the
bare minimum but I wasn't you know
extravagant I would be home out to my
pack lunches out and I would kind of
like cut down on my cost but focus more
on my education and I started sending
more seminars I would watch YouTube
channels ten years ago put my first
youtube video up there as well so that
kind of helped a little bit so I was
kind of living on a very bare minimum so
I will say that in when it comes to
financial freedom the three types you
got you know financial freedom you've
got ultimate financial freedom you've
got ultimate financial freedom and
financial freedom the normal one is just
to make enough money for you to not have
to do what you got to do in order to you
to not have to work anymore
so for me I just kind of got rid of
everything all my liabilities everything
else cost me money and now actually I
only needed around twelve hundred pounds
to live
whereas when I was working my job I
needed a lot more cuz I had so much
luxuries that I didn't you know these
doodads that was taking money out of my
pocket so so what was the pitch to this
guy you meet this guy at a networking
event yeah shiny twenty thousand to
carry me for the next whatever three six
months yeah is it really is it alone
like what how are you gonna pay him back
really simple so I literally sitting
thing we never did it in a boardroom
like we are right now in my office we
did in the barbecue so what I find is
when you're pitching it's always good to
do it not within us
the area of where you expect to be pitch
you want to do it out of that
environment so more people went round
for this barbecue I remember saying to
this investor I said you know what and
we seems like you really want to get in
property but you don't have the time but
you know what I have a lot of time so
why don't I do this why don't you fund
the project
I'll do all the work I'll find the deals
I negotiate them out
I'll find investors for them you like me
go to work and you just keep 50% of
everything that was a good deal because
he would have put 25 had to put 20,000
into a proper deal anyway well now he's
got someone full-time doing it for him
and was that the first 85,000 deal that
you made no no no and so the journey
goes on so if that I mean to cut long
story short that we made a lot of money
then we lost a lot of money well I lost
a lot of money because I was naive and
young and I didn't have the right
contracts in place so I kind of got
screwed over by that business partner
and then I went to another business
partner so you know to cut long story
short we we you've got to be very
careful who you are doing partner
partnering with because every almost
like everyone I speak to you have
different business partners they also
have this whole bad experience all this
book this is part of their business
business Honda did this so you know
you've got to be so careful really
really careful and then again how do you
get off the mat I mean a lot of people
they have that or they hire the first
employee and it's very rare that your
first employee works out and a lot of
people then go back anywhere says okay
I'm never gonna hire anybody again I'm
never gonna partner with anybody again
I'm just gonna do it all myself because
at least I know it's gonna get done
right
well it comes well it comes down to
mentoring comes down to coaching like
you've got to have good coaches you have
to have good mentors you have to have
you have to educate yourself like you
can't expect to learn if you're at the
word learn le AR n kick off the elves
spells burn right so that's a word the
clue is in that word so I had to go and
find mentors how to go and get coaches
out to continually educate myself over
and over and over and over again in
order to get the right education to have
the right strategy to have the right
implementation and to have someone hold
me accountable you want to lose weight
fastest way to do it get yourself a
personal trainer what I love about your
story is every step along the way every
time you've seen this big growth there's
always been some mentorship component to
it yeah and now you're also as much as
you're still continued to learn you're
giving back and helping and trying to be
the mentor for so many people which is
at least am i understanding why wealth
dragons is here to try to be that mentor
virtually through the app for so many
people yeah for people what I love about
your mentorship philosophy is just find
somebody and say hey what are you
working on and how can I help you how
can I be of service in what you're doing
what's the process is it is it a simple
eyes find an event that's happening in
your area around the thing you want to
get into whether it's real estate or
entrepreneurship and just go up to the
keynote speaker and and tell him or her
that that is literally exactly what I
did I mean you know before I did this
whole how I got into people also asked
me how did you get into the film
industry so I work for a company called
Framestore CFC and they they worked on
films like The Avengers they just
finished the Avengers actually they did
Harry Potter they did x-men all the big
multi multi-million dollar projects and
so how did I get a job there so when I
was at university I had a student loan
so in the UK we have something for
student loans and we have to pay for
education right so I used my student
loan instead of on my education at
University I took a trip to Copenhagen
and I attended an event called the 3d
festival and that Sweeny festival
where's all the keynote speakers from
all the top animators in the world on
all the films like Star Wars
Nader's you know all the Disney movies
and literally I would sit the back and
after they would finish the keynote
speech I walk directly up to now say hey
loved your speech I'm a student from
whole University I'm studying animation
I would love to you know come to your
studios to to help out in any way I can
whether that's getting coffee sandwiches
whatever it is and you know from about
10 or 20 different speakers I asked one
of them his name is Chris Cook you said
yes so he had me go down there so there
was comfort I don't have you heard of a
band called the gorillas you know P oh
the pain
so they passing pictures what they were
the people responsible for all the
characters and so they did all the
animation so I went there for my summer
and term so I got a place in London
couldn't afford to live in London so I
stabbed my uncle James so I literally
stayed in his front room for about three
months and so in that summer break I
every day I would be commuting I was
broke I had no money I took borrowed beg
steal you know of my friends and family
and literally borrow the money from them
just so I could survive and luckily my
uncle put you know put me otherwise I've
never been able to afford to do that so
I would have to every single digit forty
mean journey in but I'd be the first one
to show all the animators would show up
and I would literally what do you want
what would I want for breakfast today I
want the coffee and I'll go get
everybody team coffees and at the end of
the day all the animators would leave
apart from maybe three or four animators
I'd be there now it's like what do you
want the dinner I'll go out to I'll go
to McDonald's I'll go to Burger King
I'll bring some stuff back for you and
so these animator yourself become my
friends and then one of them said to me
said Jon soul what are you working on I
said I'm just here to learn from you
guys and I'd love to know how this
technology works and said hey when it
comes down sit next to me so he
literally booted up the computer open up
a brand new scene and loaded up the main
character from the gorillas on the oh my
god and he said you see this is handling
if you move it like this to Omni so why
do you give the try so every day I was
there I was learning and and and and by
the end of it I got pretty good and then
so Chris Cook who saw my animation
that's all you know what you got a lot
of talent when you graduate
give me a call so when I graduated
in fact before I even graduated I was
headhunted because I just kept doing
these other things that I learned I'm
just putting them onto forums and people
would start spotting then I got head
hunted then my first company I worked
for was a company called Lionhead
Studios which made a company called a
game called black and white so in their
90s that was one of the biggest game
that everybody played and so that's how
I got and I use the same philosophy now
for when I started business so then I
started going into business networking
events I've talked to people but of
course now you gotta pay to go into
these workshops and conference and you
can't get in for free so then I had to
use the same strategy my uncle she gave
me three hundred and fifty pounds to
attend my first property seminar and the
deal was you give me the money the first
two deals I buy I give you fifty percent
and so he's ended up doing really well
from that and I just kept that's what I
kept doing what do you think prevents
people from being able to reach out to
mentors and create that kind of
relationship I think people just like I
mean I mean I've saw milling people
falling on social media and every day
it's like you know I get the amount of
message they give me money send me some
money
dude there's no value you know I think
you've got a you've got to give the
value like let you say it so when I
reach out to people it's like hey you
know I've seen this video that you've
done but I really take interest in what
they've done and that's why I'm so
surprised that you know exactly my story
on you know you've done your homework
which is that what makes you a great
interviewer you know so I would reach
out now I wouldn't say you know what are
you working on then I can help support
with dividin if I know what the work and
I say hey I just saw a poster were you
talking about this and I would love to
go up to greet more people by doing that
for you can you send me the link so I
can help you promote it or something
like that so a lot of people are
reaching out asking for things when they
should be reaching out offering things
hmm-what so for people who are hitting
you up on Instagram on Facebook I'm sure
the DMS are out of control for people
here to know what do you need help with
right now what's the biggest thing like
how can you add the most value to John
Lee's life right now well right now so
we have an organization here you can see
this is dollar I mean it's late now
everybody's gone home because it's you
know everyone leaves work around five
o'clock but
this is my organization back here we
actually just listed our company on the
stock exchange and the variance we did
our first IPO this year and now spend a
lot of time a lot of effort doing that
so for a lot of you who love what we do
we created an app we also created a
technology which allows people to build
membership sites in 15 minutes and if
any of you guys watching this you want
to help us spread the word
we actually have an affiliate program so
all of you if you are going to spread
the word you can get paid for it as well
so you know and what we actually do as
well is give what we call lifetime
recurring income so for example our
software cost $99 a month so people pay
$99 a month we can create our membership
sites so if everybody watching they
would like to help us spread that
message or find people that want to
create membership sites if someone
registers with your link we'll pay you
20% for like so now you guys get to earn
a recurring income so that's one way
that's what way people can help and how
would how would somebody break through
the noise you get lots of people who
sign up for the affiliates and the
companies blowing up it's amazing
congratulations
how does somebody stand out so that John
Lee actually pays attention to them well
first thing is is look end of the day so
all about results isn't it
it's like you can talk all you want but
it's about the results so I know like
you guys wanna do should go to wealth
dragons affiliate com wealth dragons
affiliate com you can register it's free
you sign up as an affiliate then our
affiliate program will send you a link
to say that you can set up your password
and in there you can get your special
links so now I can see how many people
promote it how many clicks they've got
how many impressions they've had how
many sales have made so you I could act
like numbers don't lie so you can tell
so the way you stand out is by working
hard right there's no such thing as a
get-rich-quick go get John some results
I think in even in our interaction
before we did this you graciously
offered to help me with my Facebook and
Instagram and said multiple times hey
Evan if you ever need help with your
Facebook or Instagram just let me know
and and we've got it dialed in and and
I'm it's on my part now
take you up on that offer but you know
my response was then to look at your
YouTube channel and and make a quick
video to say hey he was five thing I
think you should be blowing up you can
big on YouTube here's five things you
can work on to get your YouTube channel
up to a higher level and so even just
sharing the people are watching if you
have a valuable skill that that mentor
of yours needs it could be time right so
as you were seeing with your first
mentor in real estate he didn't have the
time you did so you gonna go off and do
it but maybe young people have a talent
or a skill that the mentor doesn't have
that they can help out with as well yeah
yeah absolutely
so so this so we call it skin in the
game through money because when people
put money like do you know how many
investors when we were raising millions
of pounds for our company a lot of me
that's like yeah we'll invest in that
company yeah and when the time came I
said oh you said you want to invest
hundred grand here's our back account
details and I would say a big chunk of
those investors I said the one invest
did not invest so you got to put the
money where your mouth is and put some
skin in the game that's the first way
the second way is what we call sweat
equity so show me with action and
results live example you can't see this
but we've got Martin here who is our
video guy and this guy worked so hard in
terms of editing and all the content you
see on social media been edited by this
guy so he's like when he's at home he's
sending messages but hey John I got this
idea for this we just filmed the whole
bunch we just did a quick tour around
and it's just amazing I mean you gonna
be joining me for tour as well so in the
neck neck in a couple of weeks on our
being speaking on stage before Gary Vee
and Brancato on the three and a half
thousand people can join me on that tour
and goodbye in Malaysia and then Bali so
we're doing this whole tour and you know
it's like you've got to take away time
from his family and his his girlfriend
to do this all he's doing whatever case
that's putting skin in the game talking
about the decision to go public not
public with your company but for you to
be upfront to be the guy to be making
videos to hire Martin to do all this
stuff why come out and be be upfront
where most CEOs are hiding they're just
building their business quietly why does
it mean so much for you to get in front
of the camera and share a message well
I'm a huge Apple fan and when I read
Steve Jobs autobiography one thing I
learned in there is that you don't do
things necessarily for other people you
do them for yourself as you've must surf
you must first serve yourself before you
can serve with the people like when
you're on the plane when the mass drops
you've got to put yourself first before
somebody else otherwise you're born
conscious so how you can help with the
people unless until you can help
yourself so I went through this whole
journey of being skeptical about or you
can't do this financial freedom Mellark
yeah those OBS until I became one of the
people that was a participant so ten
years ago I read this book a Chiquita
cut me a copy of my book the second copy
of that book I'll not show you this
because the front cut this book a lot of
you probably heard the book Rich Dad
Poor Dad when I read that book it
changed my life and literally as soon as
I finished it I was telling everybody
but everyone who would come into my you
know within a close proximity oh my god
read this book and I was telling because
I would had this aha moment that would
just change everything
like I never need to commit passive
income I knew about active income or not
passive income and so when I started
learning this stuff and it came true for
me it became my duty to make it true for
the people because the certain I'll tell
you one of the reasons why I went public
in this is I wanted to tell people mine
share my journey but the reason why we
went public and didn't IPO is because
all of my company company right now is
transparent you can't say all your scan
your this and all you say you're a
millionaire but prove it well you can go
to the stock exchange you can put my
share price and they'll say my market
cap and I own this a lot of people who
say they're millionaires they can't
prove it you can Liesl I'm beginning you
can do it there's no transparency one of
the reasons why I wanted to take a
company public was to be fully
transparent so no one could say anything
and you know interesting enough I wrote
my third book that came out now don't
you see this but it says the front block
the cover says endorsed by the co author
of Rich Dad Poor Dad so my book just got
an endorsement from the core for a Rich
Dad Poor Dad and the Rich Dad Poor Dad
book is what changed my life so it's
full circle this is my way of giving
back that will change my life I want you
can change other people's life it's not
about the money for me anymore I don't
need the money I can tell you right now
I have to do this stuff I can just stay
home and watch Netflix but what's the
point what legacy like my daughter is
one years old now my daughter when she
grows up what legacy my leaving behind
and to answer your question Steve Jobs
that whole legacy of Steve Jobs not here
but he's still being remembered so it's
a question is how do you want to be
remembered and that's for me one of the
biggest reasons why I do this I move my
camera over just a little bit because we
got put a dent put a dent in universe
well I mean what I love about what
you're doing is you've had so much
mentorship over over the years and now
you are the mentor for millions of
people even though most people you'll
never meet one-on-one I know a lot of
your mentorships have been either
through a book or through actually like
connecting with them and having coffee
and working through problems but now
with the internet you're able to reach
millions of people with your message and
get it out there so the next John Lee's
coming through the system you can learn
from you even if their parents or their
family or their you know siblings or
friends aren't you know on board with
their plans and their ideas yeah what
are the I mean learning is so important
for you what are the things that you're
most interested in learning now I'm
learning one big thing from these helps
so I'm trying to do a lot of fun so I
was it so one of my routines he's going
to the gym every day so I was at the gym
this morning how's the gym day before
that and so for me is about program and
mental health to make myself bulletproof
I wanted myself in public grief I want
to learn things I'm learning is how do i
optimize myself so I can I'm the most
productive so I've been learning things
like yoga breathing techniques and peter
out two ways del to all these different
meditation techniques I'm learning a lot
about diet nutrition as well so I'm
cleaning up my diet so I'm you know not
eating sugary foods carb is that kind of
stuff so if you want your body to
perform like a Ferrari you have to put
the right fuel into it if you put like
if you put
rubbish fuel into a Ferrari it doesn't
perform as well as it should so I don't
want to operate my life at like 80
percent or 85 but I want to do it a
thousand percent as much as there as I
can I'm trying to figure out a way to
get less sleep it's not working so high
average around five or six hours a time
essentially I know six really important
I started doing some research on and
sleep where you can get like four or
five hours a week of good quality and
then you stopped napping fifteen minutes
every four or five hours throughout the
day so I've been testing that out as
well that seems to work pretty well and
but yeah for me it's and I'm looking a
lot to my health because health is well
no point being the richest person in the
graveyard
so so fuel into the Lamborghini into
this Ferrari right because entrepreneurs
by Lamborghinis not Ferraris what's the
biggest that's a throwback to one of
John's other interviews if you what's
the biggest thing you've learned like so
you're on this health kick now what's
the most surprising thing that you
picked up that you've you've applied
that you wouldn't have believed the year
ago um so one thing is really important
so my gym so I go to David Lough gym at
this machine and it's kind of like you
hold on to it and you send electric
waves to your body mat measures body fat
muscle water so you'll see here so I
drink one of these every day all right
so the the water here in something is
5.8 alkaline does anyone got something
special so when I drink this water
staying hydrated is key I mean right now
last year we ran 117 events next year is
gonna probably even more than that every
week I'm traveling to a different
country I just got from Berlin we did
Slovakia we did Amsterdam we're back in
London bubble event this weekend in
event thanks weekend and we back in
Singapore Malaysia - bye and then Bali
and then back to London again so
hydration is I didn't know how important
water was until I really started
hydrating I mean like it's a difference
between getting to flow every single
time versus hitting that a lot like why
can't I work why can't I think straight
how come always getting distracted
so water having the right water intakes
and the types of water and different
alkaline levels
I found make a really big impact to me
second thing is I learned something a
good friend of mine so I have a friend
of mine he just just visit his name is
Jim quick and he talked about these
different mind peaks and troughs so he
taught he taught this to me I said John
you work so hard like you're working
like 12 13 hour days straight and like
yeah yeah getting to put sometimes you
just gotta you know have these peaks and
troughs so what do you mean he said you
know when you watch your film like you
always remember the beginning of the end
but you never remember the middle so no
yeah it's good point
did you know why should why and he said
because there's just a definitely start
and end now in your work you want to be
more productive you want it so
productive you want to go slower and you
gain more so what I started to do
recently is doing these like peaks and
troughs so the more times I take a break
so it could just be just like you know
standing up doing stretch doing a
breathing exercise and then it would
just reset my attention and so that
would be more productive sometimes going
too slow means getting more so dance
another thing that so all of these like
bio hacks in these mine hacks is so
important for entrepreneurs if you want
to optimize at that next level
cuz this good cuz his wife restore him
to gain space she spends a year in space
and he comes down to earth and you can't
walk why I could got no muscle he's
muscle just all deteriorates and so if
you think about it why this must have
been Gary because it's not having
pressure of gravity or or resistance on
his body while he's in space so the
reason why we have to do a lot of mind
stuff is as entrepreneurs be constantly
having it's like so on every day's that
a hammer is knocking on your head every
single day all right as an entrepreneur
we've gotta learn to manage that and
manage our thoughts our feelings and our
state to be able to move through that
day and that'll makes a stronger I'm
looking forward to the John Lee course
on wealth dragons attacking all the bio
hacks you've learned over the years cool
two last questions one if somebody is
gonna is gonna meet you on tour
in Bali or wherever they're gonna be and
they want to impress you they're gonna
show up with the right alkaline bottle
of water after the end you just had a
crazy long speech you know change allows
everybody in what's the non sugary snack
or food that they should also show up
with to say here you go you might enjoy
this do you know so I have a very strict
routine so my drive Sarge Ali sting
driving you can have eight years so he
knows my preference I was setting so
when I get in the car yes so I listen to
a radio straighter since you got magic
and then we have it in volume level 1
the copy - it's too loud so I gotta
think and go to work I sit on the left
hand side at the back and always have a
double expresso in the morning which is
in the cup holder and the temperature
your 21.5 degrees can't be too cold as
well right so every setting when I speak
on stage my promote is all around the
world that promote me every time I take
a break they always bring a double
expresso with a banana and that's all I
have and then if you call my desk over
there I would have a handful of nuts so
I'm always eating like almonds you know
like just a handful of nuts is like to
sustain the energy so that's kind of
like my default banana and that's
almonds don't bring double espresso
coffee from Starbucks take notes guys
take notes if you mean John show up with
a banana final message to entrepreneurs
watching they're on the cusp they know
there's more inside them there they feel
like like this is their time they're
capable of more but they just need that
extra push what would you tell them look
the sooner you start the faster you're
gonna fail the more you can get done
sometimes you don't know whether
something's gonna work out or not
intimate right but you know I actually
did if I can let me show you something
like so I just did this this this new
meaning of fear so you probably heard
that folks evidence appears real or face
everything I'm branded what I created
what another
can't find it for this is that this is a
new meaning of fear that I wanna I want
everybody to listen to all right there
it is so feel the other process all
right
educate yourself to be risk what
everything is going to happen or results
or Consequences take action again
experience and reward yourself and
feedback and keep doing this so this
formula this process that I I guess its
new meaning of fear that I sort of
incorporated over the last ten years is
what I stopped doing I would say to
people entrepreneurship it's not right
it's not wrong it's what you make of it
so I didn't know that take my company
public would be the right thing but I
knew that if I want something big every
big company has taken the company public
so when we eventually hit 100 million
valuation then we hit a billion dollar
valuation that can only happen if you
want bigger public you can't imagine how
many how much sales you'd have to make
to make a billion or even a you know ten
unit 100 million you can't
it all comes from valuation so I knew
that by my business partner you know
Vincent Wong the guy's a genius
she's the one that that said you know
what it's not about making the right or
wrong decision it's making a decision
right I like it John agrees all this
time today man if you want people to
where's their next step
but the appFolio on on social what do
you want people to do next
yeah I mean if you love the content I do
just share it if you want to become a
wealth dragons affiliate go to wealth
dragons Affiliate calm you should want
to text me if you want my number we have
a text community just go back to my
Instagram so I love you follow me mr.
Brown and just text the number you can
go on out community but yeah if you just
keep an eye out I'm speaking all around
the world and all of literally Singapore
Malaysia Dubai I've been invited
Australia but I think it's a little bit
too far food supplies father 20-hour
flight so I don't think I fancy that but
yeah I mean I'll and hopefully I you in
New York right now I'm in Toronto turn
off her on was beautiful
you tell me or anytime soon well I
brought my family there too when was he
about two years ago they went to Toronto
the Chinese food there is amazing by the
way so good and then we flew from
Toronto down to Vegas because my parents
wants to see Celine Dion in concert so
yeah but I love it yeah I would love to
you next time you're in London
give me a make it happen we'll make it
happen hey we should get you come
speaking one of our events man let me
know we'll make it happen
yeah well next time you roll but let me
know and then we can sort of juggle them
thank you John I appreciate all of the
time thank you so much see you later bye
take care if you want to see the one on
one I did with Tony Robbins check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the amount of money
it's the amount of time time is your
greatest friend here and if you get in
the game you're gonna win